well 52 year old eric echavarria was
killed just down the street from where
he lived tonight as you can imagine
his family is still in shock they tell
me eric was heading home from picking up
food for his son when
this crash happened now these are photos
the family shared with me earlier today
eric's wife ann marie tells me he leaves
behind a son stepchildren and a grant
and grandchildren
he was a military veteran and a
custodian for nearly 20 years at ccsd
anne marie has a message for those who
may be going out tonight
don't drive under the influence and
don't speed
he's a great dad great husband
he's living back behind her
fourteen-year-old son
and four step kids and
six grandkids um great guy great
provider
i'm actually there's a loss of words
that hasn't really sunk in yet
i'm trying the best i can
i spoke to a man who lives at the home
where this crash happened he says fort
apache is a road
known to many in that area for speeders
he wants to see more enforcement in that
area to
slow people down now the family plans to
hold a vigil this sunday at 6 pm near
where this crash happened at furnace
gulch
and fort apache reporting live joe
mohler 8 news now